[Music]
okay neil here's one for you
okay okay all right so you give me a
week rest here but you're not
okay oh not at all no no rest for the
weary rest for the weary
all right what do you have okay so
in space how much
does an astronaut weigh
you see weight is a is it's not what you
think it is
you remember we did one of these where
we talked about mass
versus weight do you remember that right
we talked about that
and i said you want to weigh less go to
the top of a mountain
okay you'll burn calories getting up
there so you'll get
you'll get you lose a little bit of
weight for that but at the top of your
mount you're farther away from earth
center
and you run the math you weigh a little
bit less it out nothing
significant not nothing large but a
measurable amount
okay right it's not going to replace
it's not going to replace your p90x
workout
exactly thank you right
not only that you you don't weigh as
much
in air as you would in a vacuum okay
because air has a buoyant force that
makes you weigh a little less
yeah than you would if there was no air
around you we don't even think about
that
that doesn't even but but a helium
balloon knows everything about that
right that's so funny you remember that
right helium balloon cares what the
buoyant force of the air is on
it because it wants to float at the top
of the air
okay so i ask you you know what and what
do you weigh
when you're in the water if i say chuck
what do you weigh
and you'll probably give me your weight
on dry land
right but your weight in the water since
you're about the density of water
your weight is basically zero really
some people float some people sink and
on average people just sort of bob there
right that means you weigh nothing
that's you're weightless in the water
in fact nasa trains astronauts
in a huge swimming pool to simulate what
it'd be like to be weightless in space
do you realize there's a swimming pool
big enough to submerge
an entire mock-up of the hubble space
telescope
and to put in astronauts in there with
tools to work on it
okay that's the pool i want i want to
swim in that's a badass pool right
i think it's the biggest swimming pool
in the world actually yeah that that
that pool is dope
okay yeah and it's and i'm sure it's
more than three feet
because but there's no diving board
right yeah only there was a diving board
that pool would be amazing let me dive
down the tube of the hubble telescope
and if they had a water slide too oh my
god
so here's the thing when we think of the
blue whale for example the largest
animal there ever was by the way point
of pride
blue whale is a mammal okay so mammals
have the record they're bigger than
dinosaurs ever
we can say well how much does it weigh
and you look it up and you google it
it'll give you a weight
for the for that whale a full-grown
whale
but no excuse me that
that's if you took it out of the water
put it on land and put it on a scale
right but that's not where it lives
that's not its environment
no by the way
you have to weigh it in the water and
when you do that it weighs zero
that's why whales can just hang there
yeah it is looked and
it's such a beautiful thing okay if they
had weight in the water they would sink
right so they're just there they're very
close to zero
so they still have all the mass so i'm
saying we we don't really
think of the word weight the way we
ought to in
a sort of physically significant way
that that's
i just want to put that out there okay
whales weigh
nothing in the water and they don't hang
out on land so the weight on land is
kind of irrelevant
to us and to them okay so really
we should find a way to think about how
much mass they contain rather than
simply how much they weigh and usually
that's what people mean when they say
that
right but i just want to try to be clear
about that
physically clear about that and whales
are a lot of blubber so
you know muscle weighs more than fat so
probably not a lot of mass there
no no it's a lot no there's still a lot
of man there's still a lot of mass
i know i'm just trying to i'm just
trying to
not body shame the whale that's all [ __ ]
i don't want to body shame the whale
that's
the one who said they got blubber you
started it
[Laughter]
all right so now uh astronauts
in orbit weigh
precisely zero
precise zero okay
and it's not because they're far away
from earth
as i've said in other others of these
how far away is the astronaut from earth
in if they visit the space station
three-eighths of an inch
above this a schoolroom globe if you
shrunk it all down to that
be three-eighths of an inch away right
that's close
it's a fingernail right so finger yeah
the width of your finger
uh less even yes less than yeah yeah
yeah
so so that's the distance right so you
can't tell me oh they're in space
they've left gravity no no
if you've left gravity by being in orbit
what the hell is holding the moon in
orbit
okay right what do you think the moon is
orbiting of course
the moon feels earth gravity and it
could also be you know the moon
it's kind of sweet on the earth so
so uh and there was a a a well-known
uh news announcer back in the 1960s
who when the apollo astronauts were
headed to the moon for the first time
they said the apollo astronauts as of 8
30 this morning
whatever time it was have officially
left the gravitational pull of the earth
it's like no they actually said that on
on this yes
yes yes yes you can't leave the
gravitational pull of the earth
on route to the moon if the moon is
orbiting earth
right okay so i don't think they thought
that through
and in fact in the equations earth's
gravitational field
gets less and less and less as you go
out in space but it never actually hits
zero
until you get to infinity okay so
you tell me when you get to infinity
call me and we'll talk
so the reason why they're weightless has
nothing to do with their distance from
earth
it has to do with the fact that they
were falling towards earth
wow free fall so i put you in an
elevator shaft and a tall building and i
cut
cut the cable right okay no i put you in
the elevator you're just standing there
right so here we go
and you're standing on a scale that has
a spring so you're squeezing the spring
and it shows your weight
let's just be use round numbers to say
you're 200 pounds okay so there you are
the scale registers 200 pounds because
you're squeezing the scale
okay gravity is pulling on you to
squeeze the spring
to indicate the measure okay now now i
now i cut the elevator cable okay
so what now happens the elevator drops
right the scale drops right
you drop right all three of you are now
falling at exactly the same rate right
so there is no net force of u
on the spring right there's right so
while you are falling you weigh zero and
this the scale will say zero because
i will say zero because there will be no
compression to measure
correct and here's another measure of
that you ready let's say you're in an
elevator and it's just standing there
you're holding uh
you know from my professor angle i say
you're holding a piece of chalk
but no one holds chalk so what are you
holding find a
holding a ball okay okay there you go
if you let go of the ball it drops to
the ground right
okay right in fact in fact
drop it is synonymous with let go
because gravity does that work
right the phrase drop it you just let go
right you could just say let go and it
means drop it
all right because we live in a
gravitational field
that that doesn't work in a cop movie
though it's just
sorry let go the gun let
let go
they do say drop them they do yeah all
right and unless you're black in which
case they just that's a whole other
thing
all right so let's go so so now what
happened now i cut the elevator cable
now you begin to fall now you're
standing there holding the ball
now let go of the ball right well you're
falling
the ball is falling at exactly the same
rate you are so it'll appear to float in
front of your face
right but really you're not floating
you're just falling
everybody's falling but from your point
of view you're saying to yourself
wow it's floating i'm floating
i you do this until you die when the
elevator hits the bottom
right exactly it's a beautiful
experiment until you're a pile of goo
when the elevator hits the bottom yeah
and the ball survives of course
the ball bounces yes right you know
so here's the deal okay i'm telling you
the astronauts in orbit around the earth
are falling towards earth
right in free fall just like you in the
elevator cable that i just cut
right all right now the now the reason
why they don't hit earth
because they have really fast sideways
motion
so watch what happens okay watch what
happens
here you are in an elevator and you know
you're gonna hit the ground and you're
gonna die
okay now i'm gonna say all right let's
take this elevator
and move it sideways really fast
okay well how fast should it go let's
move it sideways so fast
so by the time it drops a foot let's say
earth has curved a foot away from it
you drop five feet earth has curved five
feet away from it
so whatever distance you have fallen the
curvature of earth because you're
traveling so fast
downrange the curvature of the earth
cancels it out
it cancels it out wow precisely
that's perfect and there's one speed
for which that is true and that is if
you go sideways
five miles per second wow
on earth so you go sideways five miles
per second
at that speed you will free fall to
earth at exactly the same rate earth
curves away from you
you will never hit earth and we have
another word for this because rather if
you never hit earth this will just keep
going
right you just go come back where you
started and you keep going
we have a word for that it's called
orbit
so orbit is free fall
with high sideways velocity around the
earth and that's why
people say oh we launched the rocket
into space today
what you really did was have you ever
watched a rocket more than just a couple
of minutes after the launch pad
yeah okay okay what does it do it's
downrange it starts to careen off
like most of the energy that's launching
that rocket is not to get it into space
no it's to give it that sideways motion
at five miles per second
so that it can sustain and orbit around
the earth
that's pretty dope it's totally dope and
you know who first figured this out
my man no don't even say it
isaac newton my man isaac newton
okay he drew a picture he had earth okay
and he drew a little mountain and he had
a little was it a cannon or something at
the top of the mountain he said what
happens if you shoot the cannon out
sideways
okay and it just hits the ground suppose
you give it more speed
it'll go farther before it hits the
ground let's giving it more and more
speed and as you
follow this diagram the cannonball
continues
around the earth but still hits earth is
there a speed
where it goes all the way around the
earth does not hit earth and it hits you
in the back of the head
but you duck and the cannonball
continues
is there a speed for that yes and he
figured out what that speed is
and that's the speed of orbit around the
earth and like i said
that's five miles per second wow isaac
newton invented orbits
with that simple diagram and in so doing
he he merged our understanding of
falling objects
with the orbit of the moon around the
earth this was his revelation when he
watched the apple fall
he didn't hit him on the head by the way
that's right he watched the apple fall
straight down
and he sees the moon in orbit around the
earth
and he said this is exactly the same
phenomenon wow
except the moon is going sideways so
that it doesn't hit the earth so the
moon
in earth's gravity is weightless because
it's in free fall around the earth there
you go
oh wow that's that's amazing okay so now
i just gotta i got to put this out there
the movie
add astra okay yes with uh matt damon
no not i'm sorry sorry wait don't tell
me don't tell me
because that's the martian uh
leading man straight yeah um that's brad
pitt
looking for his dad who is tommy lee
jones correct correct okay so
in that movie um they knew correctly
that you don't have to wait three days
to get to the moon that's that's like a
sort of a minimum energy transfer to the
moon
where you fire your rockets until you
have enough to sort of
get into the moon's pull and then the
moon pulls you down so you use minimal
fuel
but if you want to get there you can get
there in a few hours you just use a lot
of
fuel okay if your rockets are burning
on your ship you have weight on that
ship
because it's accelerating towards you
right okay that is no different from you
having weight standing here on earth
because earth the force of gravity is
that same phenomenon
right okay so so if i go in a ship
and i don't care where i am in the
universe if i'm accelerating the ship
at 9.8 meters per second per second
that's the acceleration of gravity on
earth if i accelerate the ship
at that speed in any direction i can
stand up at the bottom of this ship and
it is though i'm standing on earth
and what i'm telling you is that in that
movie they show people jetting around
the solar system because it's the future
and the rockets are always ignited and
everyone's floating in the ship
no no no didn't it wouldn't have worked
like that
totally wrong okay so what would happen
is they would have been pinned up
against pinned up against the thing if
it's
strong acceleration that's right because
what's happening is at any given moment
the whole system is going at a certain
speed okay
but if it's accelerating then the ship
is accelerating towards you
right and so it's going to come up
against you and put a scale between
there you're going to have
an equivalent weight on that ship wow so
space is not inherently a weightless
place
unless you are free-falling towards one
place or another and to make that happen
you can't have rockets firing
just got to have a sideways motion going
on around the earth
around the earth or you launch from from
the earth
and you reach up and you turn off your
rockets and then you
fall towards the moon right then you're
weightless that whole way but the moment
you turn on the rockets
you you're gonna pin to the side the
back the front
and so in fact they're long-term plans
to go to mars
if you don't want to lose bone mass and
all this and you don't want to rotate
the ship
you accelerate halfway there okay right
and then you have to decelerate
otherwise you'll miss more so what they
do is
then they turn the rocket around right
okay then you decelerate but in either
case
you can have the equivalent of one g one
g and you can have earth gravity the
whole way
wow look at that and you'll get there
like in weeks a couple of weeks
that's accelerated and i think maybe
even faster rather than the nine ten
months that it normally takes
yeah that's that's the premise behind
the expanse the movie the expanse
okay no i mean not the movie the the
series series that's next to my on my
on my binge list yeah definitely very
last thing because we're out of time
okay uh so just to be clear there are
three ways to
to simulate gravity one of them is just
be on earth and let's call that real
gravity
okay another way is to accelerate
something at the acceleration of gravity
right and the third way is you can
rotate something and then the
centrifugal force
that wants to fling you outwards that
you'll read that as a
gravitational force and so that's where
you'd have a ring
so if you did rotate a ring you'd you'd
walk around on the outer rim as they
shown
famously in the movie 2001 right a space
odyssey
so so there you have it going into space
does not automatically make you
weightless
only a free fall towards an object will
very cool
and the thing that i took away from this
talk most is
if you shoot a cannon off a side of a
mountain at
uh five miles per second you should duck
duck
duck 88 minutes later yeah that's how
long it'll take
that's cool oh by the way that
calculation
we're not gonna get into it here but
i'll just tell you if you dig a hole
through the earth
going through the center and coming out
the other side um and then you drop
something through
it'll fall towards the center overshoot
the center come out the other side
and if nobody grabs it it'll then bob
back down
and come back into your hand that round
trip
also takes 88 minutes nice yes
yes oh man well i'm going to start i'm
going to start digging now because i got
one more one more you ready just while
we're on the subject
uh earth's equator feels a little bit of
centrifugal force so you weigh a little
bit less on the equator than you do at
other latitudes i think we talked about
that
in another explainer video so if i speed
up earth
you'll weigh less and less and less and
less sweet
there's a speed with which i can spin
earth where you weigh so much less
that you weigh zero okay i'm on
what speed that is at the equator you
know what speed that is
78 rpm
[Laughter]
chuck how old are you so that speed
so if you if so if the equator makes one
full spin in 88 minutes
right you're weightless there you go
you'll just hover over the ground
and so basically at that point you're in
orbit around the earth
it's all the same number right that's
what's cool about it
that is cool once every 88 minutes
everyone on the equator is weightless
sweet got to end it there chuck all
right
that was cool i'm going to ecuador
what a coincidence they're named ecuador
and they're on the equator
who would have thought
all right this has been another star
talk explainer chuck always good to have
you
always a pleasure neil degrasse tyson
here keep looking up
you